Why is a Typical Work Day is 8 Hours Long?
During the Industrial Revolution, companies
attempted to maximize the output of their
factories by keeping them running as many
hours as possible, typically implementing
a “sun up to sun down” work day.
Wages were also extremely low, so workers
themselves often needed to work these long
shifts just to get by, including often sending
their children to work in the factories as
well, rather than getting them educated.
With little representation, education, or
options, factory workers also tended to work
in horrible working conditions to go along
with the bad hours.
The typical work day at this time lasted anywhere
from 10-18 hours per day, six days a week.
This all began to change in the 19th century.
The first to suggest an eight hour work day
for everyone was a British man by the name
of Robert Owen, who was also one of the founders
of socialism.
Owen felt that the work day should be divided
into thirds, with workers getting equal time
to themselves and to sleep as they do for
work.
Thus, in 1817, he began campaigning for an
eight hour working day for all workers, coining
the phrase, “Eight hours labour, eight hours
recreation, eight hours rest.”
Unfortunately, this did not catch on for some
time, though throughout the 19th century a
series of Factories Acts were passed that
steadily improved working conditions and reduced
work hours for factory workers.
For instance, The Factories Act of 1847 stipulated
that women and children were to be granted
a ten hour work day, thus only having to work
60 hours per week.
The eight hour work day cause was taken up
once again in Britain in 1884 by Tom Mann
who was part of the Social Democratic Federation.
Mann subsequently formed an “Eight Hour
League” whose sole goal was to get the eight
hour work day established.
Their biggest victory came when they managed
to convince the Trades Union Congress, which
represents the majority of unions in Britain-
and does so even to this day- to establish
the eight hour work day as one of their primary
goals, which they subsequently began to work
towards.
The push for a shorter work day began earlier
in the United States, in 1791, with workers
in Philadelphia striking for a ten hour total
work day that would include two hours for
meals.
By the 1830s, support for eight hour work
days was shared among the majority of the
working class people in the United States,
but still failed to find support among business
owners.
Over the next few decades, workers continued
to hold strikes demanding shorter working
hours and gradually things began improving.
Momentum for the cause particularly picked
up with several “Eight Hour Leagues” forming
in the United States, as Mann had formed in
Britain around this same time.
In 1884, the Federation of Organized Trades
and Labor Unions declared that May 1, 1886
would be the first day that an eight hour
work day would be made mandatory.
This, of course, was neither backed by any
federal mandate nor the businesses themselves
and relied on workers striking and raising
a general ruckus to drive the point home.
When May 1, 1886 arrived, the first ever May
Day parade was held with 350,000 workers walking
off their jobs protesting for the eight hour
work day.
Progress was still slow though and it wasn’t
until 1905 that industries began implementing
the eight hour work day on their own accord.
One of the first businesses to implement this
was the Ford Motor Company, in 1914, which
not only cut the standard work day to eight
hours, but also doubled their worker’s pay
in the process.
To the shock of many industries, this resulted
in Ford’s productivity off of these same
workers, but with fewer hours, actually increasing
significantly and Ford’s profit margins
doubled within two years after implementing
this change.
This encouraged other companies to adopt the
shorter, eight hour work day as a standard
for their employees.
Finally, in 1937 the eight hour work day was
standardized in the United States and regulated
by the federal government according to the
Fair Labor Standards Act.
It stipulated that workers were not to work
more than 44 hours per week and any hours
over 40 required of the worker were to be
paid with overtime bonuses added to their
normal pay rate.